for a while seeing a police officer in
uniform I'd have like flashbacks
if something happened to me again I
don't think I'd ever report it this is a
serving police officer so traumatized by
abuse from a fellow officer that she's
questioning her own force of homicide
and her testimony suggests there might
be the need for a Louise Casey style
review into sexism and other failings in
every police force not just London's
Sally says the sexism starts the moment
you arrive
the conversations quickly turn sexual
right
I was sort of propositioned
you feel like you're fresh meat that's
the attitude you feel like fresh meat
coming in
I want to start speak out about it and
start telling people
everyone was like oh yeah he's doing it
to me oh yeah he's done it to me and
it's always the same officers
homicide constabulary was rated
outstanding by the police inspectorate
but Sally says when it became known
she'd reported a fellow officer for
sexual violence her colleagues rallied
around him I was ostracized given cold
shoulder so I had to be stared at or
given dirty looks
they were at school yeah bullies
after the misconduct hearing so after he
lost his job I lost count of the amount
of offices that came up to me and said I
was always being like that really yeah
and he'd been in the job a really long
time
and I thought well why have they not
said anything then yeah he basically had
the same nicknames as those monsters in
the mat
Wayne cousins was nicknamed the rapist
by fellow officers before he murdered
Sarah everard David Carrick a serial
rapist was in the same unit now the
Casey review has found the Met police's
institutionally sexist but does it go
wider Sally says in homicide for example
colleagues knew that one predatory
officer would get vulnerable victims
details from statements to ask them on
dates and you think he was known for
this his full shift would have known
what he was like what's a full shift I
would reckon on each team I reckon 20
police officers and Sky News has
evidence of bad attitudes potentially
impacting investigations Anna alleged as
a Teenage issues being raped by a gang
of men who intimidated her into going
back to them she used what's called a
subject access request to get humbicide
police records on herself she found
these types of comments made by officers
if the reports are genuine we have a
very vulnerable victim who keeps putting
herself in danger this is a very regular
occurrence the female herself is making
lifestyle choices of her own this victim
doesn't come across as the best type of
witness victim that I've seen
that whole time I was still under Social
Services I was really vulnerable I was
on a protection plan it said how I was
getting strangled I was being sexually
assaulted I was high risk but they never
did anything to stop that it's very much
attention seeker lifestyle Choice says
maybe putting herself at risk is another
thing that comes up so they're kind of
blaming you there's no wonder the case
was never brought to court because
before it's even got there they've
completely undermined it I think they
basically set that case up to fail
in one extract they seem to accept the
alleged attacker's story saying the
victim states that she's received
injuries and these have been seen by
police officers the issue that we have
is that the suspect admits to causing
these injuries to the victim but states
that these were with consent as the
victim says she liked it it is difficult
for us to disprove this and I would
suggest the victim is too undermined in
this investigation to take her word
above that of the suspect I think it's
quite disgusting like how they can say
that someone would enjoy being injured
it makes me really angry
Louise Casey's findings have rocked
London's police force but she told Sky
News the problems are likely to be
National should there be a Louise Casey
type review into every other police
force I actually think the answer to
that is yes because I think that what we
have found there are some things that
are like vetting like sort of the
cultural issues particularly around race
and around women I think that they are
National issues and I do think we need a
wholesale change of public protection
particularly for women so we need this
across the country a proper delve into
what's going on within police forces I
think that we need a route and Branch
review of policing
after a review Anna's investigation was
reopened and for that reason homicide
police say they can't comment further
but deputy chief Constable Paul Anderson
said child sexual abuse and exploitation
is a deplorable and condemnable crime
and we're determined to bring offenders
to Justice and hold them accountable for
their actions with regard to Sally the
force says misogynistic Behavior will
not be tolerated adding there is an
existing robust process in place anyone
who exhibits any form of misogynistic or
discriminatory Behavior will be held
accountable for their actions we are
internally communicating with all
officers and staff in regards to sexual
harassment and have launched our knowing
the line campaign to raise awareness and
to fully encourage reports whether
personal or witnessed to be made to our
Professional Standards Department
Sally says she's still proud to be a
police officer but she's speaking out
because she wants her colleagues to make
the changes from within it's now
snowballed into a massive thing
because it's been hidden for so long and
Bush into the carpet that is now a
monster
the Casey review suggests that monster
needs to be exposed and acknowledged
before it can be properly tackled Jason
Farrell Sky News